how about this because next up clams
might be an aphrodisiac
but apparently new york city doesn't
need one according to the guardian noise
complaints about bedroom activity are
way up wow
people are getting busy and being real
alone about it last year there were
277 noise complaints relating to sex
queens had the most at 103 good for you
queen yeah queens manhattan had 66
brooklyn 55 the bronx 48 and staten
island had four
maybe we need to send staten island some
clowns hey
so um there were some specificities in
the complaints i'm quoting them right
now
she makes the bed squeak as if it's an
olympic event wow
i've slept through earthquakes and fires
and i couldn't sleep through this uh-huh
i love this i love this too let me tell
you something we have been through a
rough couple years go and get it get
yours go for it and if you
start
if i heard this i would not complain as
long as it's not too loud just like like
just like normal people two and a half
three minutes have fun doing your thing
have you ever like heard people you know
having having their kind of fun enough
not enough no i would celebrate it sure
and then i'd become that old lady you
know who's like
i don't know like i but i i'm listen
knock the boots do the thing have some
fun do the thing and if you know how
many of my friends are pregnant because
of the pandemic oh yeah it's such a baby
boom it is it's it's exciting every
single one of my girlfriends is pregnant
really oh my god everyone i know wow
pregnant
well i am i've never like heard people
um doing it ever but i want to so bad
and if yeah and if i did i would not
complain i would call my best friend put
it on speaker and be like listen
totally totally
don't complain i'm sure at like three in
the morning i'd probably be like all
right you know i gotta work but like i
don't think i would i would be happy for
people i'd say do it up yeah especially
speaking to you in staten island come on
let's do this step it up all right
finally oh some noodle news
that's my favorite kind of news right
yes because we are wrapping up our pasta
weed
don't say it's going away your favorite
favorite week of all right it is i love
a pasta it's my favorite food on planet
earth it is well pure wow reports tick
tocks found a new way to strain your
pasta yeah it turns out you've been
doing it wrong all along millions have
viewed this hack they say you should put
your strainer into the pot
then walk to the sink and carefully pour
out the water because look
yeah the pot the pasta never leaves the
pot you understand cause all the time
i've been like trying to hold
the the strainer and lift the thing
giving myself that facial you know and
then lifting it out and i always lose a
noodle or two what do you think
i feel like this one is a oh duh moment
like in a good way like oh yeah the only
thing i would say is don't forget to get
the mug of pasta water because it's the
magic ingredient which by the way
sometimes on that walk
is when i remember so like get it while
it's good because you'll dump that out
and then all of a sudden you'll lose
that
you can't get anything there's nothing
you can buy that compares with pasta
water so
save it
but i'm going to try this yeah just
always say you're right just a little
bit of starchy water because it will
change your sauce it's the best thing
it's the best thing you can have in the
pasta world
[Music]